los ministros de exteriores de la Unión
Europea han apoyado que se envíen 500
millones de euros más de ayuda para la
inversión y compra de armas para Ucrania
en total ya se han enviado
3.600 millones de euros por parte de la
Unión Europea a Ucrania se trata de una
ayuda que se espera se puede hacer
efectiva a lo largo de esta semana y se
pueda ratificar para que Ucrania pueda
comprar armas esta nueva ayuda se
produce en un contexto en que los países
europeos están muy divididos sobre el
envío no de carros de combate de los
tanques leopard de fabricación alemana
países como Polonia están presionando a
Alemania para poder enviar estos tanques
este país ya ha dicho que va a seguir
adelante y que va a preguntar
formalmente a Alemania este envío Berlín
de momentos muy reticente Por hacerlo
por ella misma porque teme las
consecuencias que puede tener esto en el
conflicto la Unión Europea el jefe
diplomacia europea eso sea por rey y ha
dicho que apoya este envío pero que es
una decisión de los países paralelamente
hoy los ministros de exteriores también
han apoyado un nuevo paquete de
sanciones contraerán se trata del cuarto
paquete desde que empezaron las
protestas tras el asesinato de Masha a
mini en estas nuevas sanciones se amplía
la lista de sancionados entre los que se
destaca el ministro de deportes por ser
el causante de represalias y también de
presionar a los deportistas para que no
hablen a favor de las protestas también
hay en diputados y también miembros de
los guardianes de la revolución de Irán
en total ya son más de 100 los
sancionados desde que empezaron